hello everyone youtubers and everyone
who subscribed already welcome to
another HD tutorial and in this video
I'll be showing you how to get your
YouTube videos to always play in the
highest quality without you having to
choose it to do so so I'm just going to
open any Internet browser that I usually
browse my youtube videos in and just go
to youtube com and this is actually
built into YouTube's interface so you
can do this without any sort of messing
with your computer this is actually
online so once you've signed in and just
hit the account button here and first of
all thanks to all my subscribers I have
95 right now so thank you all you guys
and right now we're going to go to the
playback setup button and as you can see
I've already chosen one of the three
defaults so the first one is choose my
video quality dynamically based on the
current connection speed that's kind of
iffy it goes up and down the second one
is I have a slow connection never play a
high quality video and this is helpful
for some people because sometimes they
might not be able to play my video in HD
because they don't have a good
connection or a fast enough processor so
it'll be a little framing and it won't
play at the smoothest quality so then
you would just check that or you just
uncheck the watch in HD link but the
second won't I've chosen is that I have
a fast connection always play always
play higher quality video when it's
available so if there's a watching each
deal and get along matically with a
little macro I guess built-in click that
watch an HD link and refresh the page
for watching in HD also you can choose
whether or not to use annotations and
show annotations but sometimes it's
helpful to just know that the person was
put in a few annotations to help before
for viewing the video but basically the
choose playback quality thing is what
this tutorial is all about so if i were
to watch any youtube video right now
that actually has a watch in HD link
then or watch in high quality link
that's also important it will also watch
in high quality then obviously it will
watch automatic and high quality so
that's basically how you do it guys and
if you have any other questions or
tutorials that you'd like me to do I
will handle it to the best of my ability
just hit that subscribe button to the
right of this page and I will
back to you in a personal message and
I'll do a video request for you so
thanks for watching this tutorial and
there are plenty more to come um that's
basically it thanks for watching peace